[Applause]
[Music]
amazing happy
Tuesday everybody yeah
tues you know when I was in college back
in the day we had something called
Mickey Mouse courses these were classes
you took where you were sure to get an
easa degrees deemed Mickey Mouse courses
were things like golf course management
media cultural studies and of course
intro to Fox and
Friends even today there are courses on
tree climbing Harry Potter Taylor Swift
but the biggest Mickey Mouse major of
them all gender
studies according to Yale Daily News
over 90% of women in gender studies
majors at the Ivy League school receive
a
grades yeah and apparently 80% of your
grade is based on how much you hate your
parents and the only way to fail is by
saying a woman has a
vagina meanwhile students who major in
science technology engineering
mathematics they receive the fewest A's
think about that the next time you're
driving over a bridge in your
car kind of redundant but it's what we
already knew the more useful your skills
are to society the tougher it is to
succeed in your field but being useless
is easy and
rewarding don't I know
it I was an English major in all Learned
was he who smelt it dealt
it Shakespeare aell but as our society
has decided to enable stud stupid ideas
now we're getting more of them it's
cause and effect we've incentivized
faulty thinking and it's everywhere just
look outside these mindless and unstable
protests are in full bloom because you
if you adopt the latest Trend you're
rewarded and the reward is mental
instability so who's behind all this
well according to new research liberal
parents are the least likely to adopt
parenting practices linked to adolescent
mental health and they're also least
likely to effectively discipline their
kids meanwhile conservative parents do
the opposite in other words tough love
works whether it's parents disciplining
children or ignoring cat when she's
crying now it could be the Brat's fault
but maybe it's starts when parents tell
their kids hey we're your friends cuz
friends care more about being liked than
being respected and so what you end up
with is a coddled kid who expects every
whim to be satisfied which then gives
bored rudderless students a way to claim
their oppressed and important and boy do
they today many young people are
embracing identity over individualism
they're following instead of leading
according to the Oregon Department of
Education the number of students who've
decided their non-binary has jumped
almost 57% from the previous year this
from a state that used to know how to
identify a be
I don't get it so why are all these
people making this claim all of a sudden
it can't be as simple as wanting to use
both the men's and the ladies room
depending on the line but how do they
all arrive at this new realization about
themselves at the exact same time to
reject millions of years of evolution I
mean while you're at it why not declare
yourself free from the laws of gravity
and Float
everywhere well it's evidence of a
social and psychological contagion all
those things flourish among the
impressionable and the weak now kids are
already that way their brains are as
formless as Joy bear and a
Mumu but perhaps the liberal style of
parenting made them even weaker unable
to develop their own self and demanding
others to accept a manufactured one they
just choose a costume it's like
thousands of kids suddenly deciding
they're Batman but fatter and without
the cool
costumes and if you question it you're
questioning who they are how dare D you
even if it's just though for one
semester and you hope it's just that
because you indulge this thing even more
the delusion can be irreversible you end
up at the worst case scenario castrating
a child because of gender
dysphoria which is nuts no pun
intended according to a new study gender
dysphoria is not a thing to be remedied
with a scalpel but a symptom of mental
illness now this isn't some Fringe
research it's from the Journal of
European Psychiatry published by
Cambridge University press researchers
looked at more than 3,000 people over a
20-year period who sought help for
gender dysphoria and they concluded that
psychiatric needs still persist
regardless of medical gender
reassignment which undermines all those
arguments we hear for transitioning you
know by standing in the way of surgery
that's going to lead to Suicide you're
putting Children at Risk so we must take
a child self-diagnosis seriously and
perform irreversible surgery to
sterilize him to decrease the this
so-called risk of suicide but the same
lead author of that study also found
that gender transition treatment wasn't
linked to a lower suicide rate so it
makes you wonder what happened to First
Do no harm now can you really blame
these kids this is what they're being
taught at schools and in culture this is
the adults in their lives the people
they've been told to trust have
abdicated the roles as teachers and
parents and for adults it's also for
attention as well for the likes for
whatever makes them happy happy the best
part is nobody can prove they're wrong
it's all based on feelings and there's
no way to disprove a feeling it's
completely unscientific but anybody who
contradicts them is a transphobe it's
kind of ironic they claim that gender
and race is what defines you but if you
disagree you're the bigot look every kid
feels like an outsider sometimes but
until now our entire Society didn't seek
to make it permanent so it's up to
everyone parents teachers doctors and
anyone with a working brain de
incentivize faulty thinking stop
rewarding the latest dumb Trends give
people young people treatment that
actually works when they need help and
for God's sake get rid of gender studies
as a
major let us welcome tonight's guest
shall we okay her skills with the Press
but lives in distress co-host I've
outnumbered Kaye
maganini the only thing this Hunter
kills is a crowd comedian Adam
Hunter custodians often mistake are for
a mop New York Times best-selling author
contributor
ctive and he trims his beard with a
writing mower New York Times bestselling
author comedian and former NWA Champion
Cyrus Kaye welcome to the show you look
fantastic in leather and I can say that
knowing HR is
watching I dare you I dare you did you
ever have have to take a gender studies
course no I paused because it was woven
into all of the international relations
courses You' think you'd be learning
about like how to avert Wars like in
Israel and Ukraine but that stuff was
all woven in yeah so instead of learning
about War and Peace you learn about
pronouns and where to pee I I am old
enough to where that wasn't a part of
this so there's this thing I don't know
if you this new term social contagion
right social contagion okay so there's
this explosion of gender dysphoria
non-binary kids in Oregon 4,000% expion
the state of New Jersey and this comes
after what the last 3 years you have
corporations pushing this you have blue
States pushing this you have Hollywood
pushing this and then social contagion
takes fire and all of a sudden everyone
is non-binary but what really got to me
in Oregon kindergarteners identifying as
non-binary my four-year-old came down
the stairs yesterday we just got home
and I go go change Blake go change
Blake's a Girl by the way I named her
before this whole social just in case
yes she's a girl very smart very smart I
was ahead of the time um I say go change
into something comfortable she comes
down in a mermaid outfit like half
dressed in like a keys July uniform not
a dead of winter outfit so my point is
she's supposed to know her gender when
she can't even dress appropriately for
the weather that is so true that is true
I remember the good old days when social
contagion was
chyia
Adam yes Adam do you have kids I do yeah
are you worried at all I mean you know
when I was a kid he man was a cartoon
and now it's a gender
pronoun I mean you're going to have to
start having two gender reveal parties
you know like one in the womb and one
when you're 10 yes uh but it is I mean
my my daughter asked me she's like can
boys get pregnant and I'm like no unless
you watch
CNN
uh but
but but I think it is how you know as
far as disciplining the kid like it is
hard it really is hard like we decide
we're not going to spank our baby we're
going to
taseer uh that's good but I do think
parents need to be tougher yeah I think
it will be did you ever take a gender
study course I I did not but I'm happy
those people are getting A's because
they're going to get five stars at Uber
[Applause]
uh it sucks would if if men could get
pregnant because now it's like people
aren't going to be sure if it's a a pot
belly or a baby bump cat uh cat um do
you think is it fair to blame liberal
parents for this I mean it feels like
these kids are becoming are more more
willing to become followers or following
a trend than they ever have before is
that because of their commi
parents that's a loaded question well as
a childless 35-year-old woman
who lives in a big city who like also
doesn't even have a friend who has
kids I don't have kids because I don't
want to decide how to raise kids and I'm
so scared of doing it wrong so I for me
to weigh in here on that I mean like I
don't know how you keep a child like
alive it no it seems so SC there's so
much that you can kill it so easily just
on accident no it's true it's true if
you forget look how many cracks on my
phone screen you know you're going to
get it like they what if it drinks
poison on accident something like that
so I mean I I think it's just I'm not
going to be like well yeah well as a
childless 35-year-old woman I think the
way that you're raising your kids is
wrong if the kids are alive I'm
impressed by you yeah it's a good point
Tyrus however you're different you have
you have a plethora a family if you will
yeah I got a cornicopia bathro yes
you've got a beniton ad especially
impressive logistically
but cat don't worry they're clever you
can set little traps for them and they
always find ways to get out of them soor
so I've been told
uh it this all goes back to to Parenting
that friendship I want to be your friend
uh I was not even on a firstname basis
with my mother ever like I recently
found out in like my 30s what her real
first name was like I had no idea so I
was like wow if I would have known that
I would have made better jokes but
quietly on the inside because you just
didn't do that but we we they can't have
it both ways especially the the really
severe liberal ones who the new Munch
hous and is there's something wrong with
my kid and they want their children to
make decisions there's a reason why when
a child commits a crime they're not
charged as an adult because the first
defense is what they're a child they're
young they're they not they don't really
know what they're doing yet so you can't
hold them to the same accountability as
you would an adult but under their way
of thinking you you can and you should
and of course if if their if their
little darling assaulted somebody at
school and they were charged as an adult
they would be outraged and like how
could you do this to whoa whoa whoa
they're old enough to decide whether
they stand or sit when they pee they're
old enough to decide what's wrong or
right in terms of assaulting people so
you can't have it both ways right so and
see that oh yeah you hit him with that
yeah
see nicely put nicely put you don't get
that on out numbered no I have seven
pages of notes for you Greg excellent
all right we shall move on up next
Biden's polls make them sweat so they
pretend Trump's a
threat that's a good if you'll be in the
New York area and would like tickets to
see Gutfeld go to foxnews.com Gutfeld
and click on the link to join our studio
audience hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else